bienvenidos a este programa especial de
economía
yo soy daniel hablando hablaremos hoy de
las inversiones no tradicionales la
llegada de la pandemia implicó una
profunda transformación en la forma en
la que siempre hemos conocido para hacer
inversiones de hecho impulsó ciertos
modelos de inversión que no eran tan
conocidos antes las acciones los bonos o
los commodities no han dejado de existir
pero ahora es común encontrar quienes
armados de buenos ahorros durante la
pandemia han desviado sus apuestas hacia
otros activos que van desde zapatillas
hasta cartas de juegos pasando por
muchos otros
y a veces obtienen una gran rentabilidad
hay una especie de boom en cripto
activos a través de los llamados nfc o
token no fungible es en español una
tecnología que está revolucionando el
mundo de los coleccionistas e inversores
veamos algunos de los ejemplos
la primera obra digital de la historia
se vendió recientemente por 69 3
millones de dólares en una subasta es de
un artista conocido como vip
desde mi perspectiva realmente creo que
este es el comienzo del arte digital el
próximo capítulo de la historia del arte
es el arte digital y esto se ha hecho
durante mucho tiempo pero no había forma
de recopilar así que realmente no había
manera de compilar mi trabajo pero ahora
hay una manera y eso es muy emocionante
para mí por su parte el fundador de
twitter jack dorsey subastó un nfc del
primer tweet de la historia este tri no
fue publicado el 21 de marzo de 2006 y
decía algo así como configurando mi
twitter su valor alcanzó los 29 millones
de dólares
por eso hemos invitado a ana gabriela
ojeda quien es abogada y experta en
block change y encripta activos y le
preguntamos primero ana gabriela que es
un token no fungible y porque estos
activos están siendo tan deseados
últimamente hola daniela bueno para mí
un gusto saludarte esther nuevamente con
ustedes en las pantallas de friends son
y forestales para conversar suerte más
términos y tan interesantes como las
inversiones no tradicionales
específicamente abriremos con los nfc en
las últimas semanas hemos leído
muchísimo ha escuchado mucho sobre como
artistas están vendiendo obras de arte
en este formato como cantante están
sacando sencillos o si llevamos este
formato y como el fanático o gente
interesada en pagar millones de dólares
que para algunos es absurdo
por estos activos digitales por así
decirlo pero tenemos que comenzar
definiendo qué es un en efectivo en este
es básicamente un activo digital que
está registrado una blogger y que es un
activo que tiene unas características de
programación que lo hacen único es decir
solamente puede existir un toque no
fungible a diferencia lo que pasa por
ejemplo con los dólares si yo tengo un
billete de un dólar lo pueden ver
cambiar fácilmente con otra persona que
tengo un billete en dólar y no me
importan hacer el intercambio porque
seguiré conservando el mismo valor con
los tokens no fungible son los nfc no
sucede lo mismo porque me toquen es
único y el de la otra persona es único y
eso es lo que añade valor hay gente que
se pregunta pero porque alguien está
pagando por ejemplo 60 millones de
dólares por la foto de una obra de arte
que puedo haberme descargado a internet
y bueno yo yo le respondo al siguiente
la gente nos está pagando por la foto de
internet la gente nos está pagando por
el tweet la gente no está pagando por
los zapatos del futbolista la gente
realmente paga por ese certificado que
lo acredita como un propietario
allí donde recibir valor y por eso es
que hasta el momento tenemos un mercado
que es algo nuevo y que está haciendo
bastante especulativo porque claramente
lo que se está haciendo es darle mucho
valor a obras que resultan cerraran webs
céntricas y que por eso llama la
atención de los fanáticos de los
inversores que tienen la posibilidad de
invertir en los mismos y yo los invito a
que veamos otro ejemplo de new york
times' en su bastón coleccionable
digital por más de 560 mil dólares era
justamente una columna editorial que
trata este llamativo fenómeno su autor
kevin gross dice en el escrito que así
como en un futuro este activo puede no
costar nada también puede darse el caso
contrario que tenerlo sea comparable a
ser el dueño de la primera transmisión
televisada de la nfc o la primera
dirección de correo electrónico de ello
él
volvemos con nuestra invitada ana
gabriela ojeda estas inversiones ana
gabriela no dejan de ser riesgosas por
estar respaldadas en la nube por eso él
ha escrito monedas todavía no están
avaladas por las autoridades económicas
para su uso oficial como divisa qué tan
alto es ese riesgo y cómo podemos
prevenirlo
mira con respecto a los riesgos e
invertir en crédito moneda son ciertos y
están allí no podemos ocultarlo yo
pudiese enumerar te los que considero
que son más recurrentes o lo que a las
personas como que me hacen pensar a
veces antes de entrar la este mundo
primero la atención marco regulatorio
obviamente hay muchos países que han
promulgado leyes para tratar de darle
forma jurídica al comercio intercambio
escrito moneda sin embargo no es la
norma no es la regla es la excepción
países como venezuela estados unidos
china rusia lo han intentado lo han
hecho pero no es ley digamos que el
común denominador y a nivel global por
lo que se hace necesario un marco
regulatorio segundo los riesgos
asociados con un mercado que es volátil
que es fluctuante por ejemplo un bis con
no sé cuesta 50.000 dólares al día
siguiente cuesta 58 mil luego puede
costar mente mil luego 30 mil por poner
un ejemplo y esto genera cierto tipo de
inseguridad para quienes quieren
invertir en un mercado que es nuevo que
en ocasiones suele ser bastante
desorganizado y hay otros riesgos que
están asociados con que las plataformas
donde se mantienen las criptas monedas
están en constante actualización
tecnológica y eso puede llevar meses
de pérdida importantes de capitales por
otra parte el riesgo asociado al
financiamiento al terrorismo al lado de
capital en fin son riesgos que si bien
son previsibles no pueden ser evitados
realmente del todo por nosotros y lo que
podemos hacer responsablemente al
invertir en créditos monedas es buscar
asesoría financiera y jurídica con
personas o con equipos especializados en
materia de loche nine cripto monedas
para tomar la mejor decisión a la hora
de invertir en las mismas y no vernos
envueltos en esquemas por ejemplo de
estafas en esquemas ponzi o en stands
donde se nos ofrece compraron en
descripto monedas y al final del día nos
vemos estafas entonces siempre la
recomendación va a ser buscar asesoría
jurídica y financiera de la mano de
profesionales expertos para tratar de
mitigar en la mayor medida posible estos
riesgos que si son previsibles también
pueden ser evitables
anagabriela le pregunto ahora cómo
explicar este fenómeno de inversiones no
tradicionales que se ha disparado en
medio de la pandemia
yo creo que el tema el fenómeno de las
inversiones no tradicionales podemos
abordarlo
de varios punto de vista el primero es
que obviamente mucha gente realiza de la
pandemia de coronavirus se quedó sin
trabajo y hay mucha gente que se quedó
en casa y está intentando hacer del
trading por ejemplo un nuevo estilo y
una nueva forma de ingresos no gente que
tiene una computadora en su internet que
está iniciándose en el mundo del
training para esto hay aplicaciones como
por ejemplo vingut que te permiten hacer
pelin sin cover de ningún tipo de
transacciones y evidentemente está
influyendo muchísimo en la forma en la
que los millennials están invirtiendo
hay otros casos muy interesantes como es
el caso de los coleccionables donde hay
plataformas por ejemplo como otis en las
que la gente puede comprar acciones de
un bien que sea raro por ejemplo una
tarjeta de la nba y un balón de básquet
que utilizó por ejemplo no sé michael
jordan en x final de la nba y entonces
las personas que si bien no puedes
comprar
el objeto completo o el valor completo
pueden comprar acciones de ese bien y
esas acciones están cotizando muy bien
están produciendo rendimientos bastante
interesantes por lo que el mercado de
los coleccionables o el mercado de los
coleccionistas no solamente ahora
enfocado en que puedas comprar un bien y
mantenerlo en tu casa y tener el
certificado de registro sino que también
tienes la opción de poder comprar
acciones que te acrediten como poseedor
de un porcentaje ínfimo mínimo de ese
bien que es raro y que expresamos por
muchos fanáticos así que bueno yo creo
que el tema el coronavirus y creo que
este nuevo empoderamiento que ha surgido
en los jóvenes y estas ganas de invertir
en cualquier bien que genere el
rendimiento está causando estragos en la
forma tradicional de invertir porque
vemos que los fondos están redirigiendo
a nuevos mecanismos de inversión
distintos a los tradicionales a los que
ya conocíamos y claramente el caso es
como el de game of nos hacen ver que los
nuevos millonarios los nuevos ricos de
los próximos 10 años definitivamente van
a hacer los milenios
bueno y continuando un poco con este
tema de las nuevas aplicaciones qué
características tienen y por lo general
son manejadas por los llamados
millennials estas nuevas aplicaciones o
estos mecanismos para invertir tienen
algunas características que son bastante
interesantes porque son características
que note a la banca tradicional primero
la posibilidad de tarifas o de
comisiones muy bajas si las comparamos
con las comisiones de la banca
tradicional segundo los tiempos de
respuesta son mucho más rápidos estamos
hablando de transacciones que pueden
hacer en 12 máximo 10 minutos mientras
que sabemos que por ejemplo para hacer
una transferencia internacional de un
país a otro tendríamos un poco más de
tres días al esperar la respuesta en las
respectivas cámaras de compensación por
ejemplo el tema que cualquier persona
puede utilizar un exchange es también es
bastante importante no necesitamos
cumplir con requisitos burocráticos para
acceder a los mismos sino que basta con
tener disponibilidad de fondos en
nuestra cuenta nacional y tener un
wallet para poder empezar a comprar oa
vender escritos quienes más lo están
utilizando en este momento de estas
aplicaciones las cuales me permite
responsablemente recomendar algunas
comodines como como veis como local
bitcoin son como christo bayern son
evidentemente los millenials
hay una bastante interesante en
latinoamérica sobre todo en venezuela de
comercios que no solamente están
invirtiendo sus utilidades o ganancias
en créditos monedas sino que vemos cada
vez más como hay locales o comercios o
empresas que están aceptando las grito
monedas como métodos de pago y que
evidentemente hacen uso de estas
aplicaciones como los exchange que
mencioné anteriormente para poder
realizar estas transacciones con
comisiones que son relativamente bajas y
con tiempo de respuestas muy corto lo
cual hace que toda la operación sea
bastante efectiva
bueno y qué efecto tienen esas nuevas
opciones sobre la forma de invertir que
hemos conocido toda la vida en la
cabrera estas inversiones que hemos
visto en los últimos días tan
interesantes en el caso de los benéficas
o de los coleccionables o de los script
activos la escrito monas en general
obviamente van a cambiar la visión de la
gente que está invirtiendo en las
personas ahora se sienten más atraídos
por invertir en cristo' activos en
cristo' monedas en coleccionables
jóvenes pp que en instrumentos
financieros tradicionales y esto pasa
mucho también por lo mediático no no
solamente creo que va a cambiar la forma
de invertir sino los instrumentos en los
que la gente está invirtiendo pero
además se vienen otros cambios
interesantes a nivel regulatorio pero
que los gobiernos terminarán por este
año definitivamente en hacer un esfuerzo
cada país tendrá seguramente un marco
normativo para regular estas
innovaciones tecnológicas financieras
vimos como méjico en el 2018 promueve
una ley la ley fintech que ha sido
pionera en la región latinoamericana y
que es referencia para todo el mundo
creo que se va a ser el próximo paso a
seguir y que evidentemente son alguno de
los efectos que interesan en este
aspecto medular a mí se me ocurre como
a replantear algunas instituciones del
derecho como por ejemplo la hipoteca qué
va a pasar con la hipoteca y habrá
posibilidad por ejemplo que pidamos un
préstamo a un banco utilizando un nfc
como garantía para poder hacer eso
válido yo creo que sí que lo veremos en
los próximos meses y probablemente
también en los próximos años
es todo un tema interesante que pues
está para debatir muchas horas más pero
que creo que nos va a hacer replantear
no solamente la forma en la que
invertimos los instrumentos en los que
invertimos sino además las relaciones
económicas y jurídicas de los
intervenientes hay otro aspecto y qué
poco se habla pero que es importante por
el medio ambiente como es la huella
carbono que dejan las operaciones en
cripto monedas y que es un elemento
cierto es un elemento que está allí que
también siento que los gobiernos tienen
que hacer algo por combatir este tema
porque evidentemente el medio ambiente
interesa a todos por igual
un tema que sin duda dejará mucho de que
hablar era anagabriela ojeda abogada y
experta en cripto activo a ella le
agradecemos y a ustedes también por
continuar con nosotros sigan con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]